so instead of this scent and this w
let's introduce a new server than you
don't so over here
consider instead of these which are
specific let's go as general as we can
okay so I'm just going to name a complex
number
what's its modulus going to be its
radius well I want it to be anything
anything okay
so I'm just going to say let's call the
radius of this oz it cuz that's the
complex number okay
now along with a modulus I need an
argument and I don't want to specify it
I don't want to be that pilot six or PI
on that or whatever I just want it to be
anything I'm gonna have a pair of them
something gonna call one of them [ __ ]
and the other one
I just need to labeled like that that's
my first complex all but he could be
anywhere right depending on what these
ends up and now I just need another one
W so I'm gonna give it gets thrown one
two this and I'm gonna give it its now
I'm going to reverse this again as you
can imagine this is going to be a little
trickier because I can't just simplify
out numbers and not just gonna like
black terms I'm just going to collect
but if I do this right and play my cards
properly I should be able to observe
this pattern happening okay so let's try
this let's multiply through what am I
going to get now it's gonna look a
little messy this is gonna be a little
bit like cleaning your desk at home you
know you're looking for something and
you're like where's this piece of paper
well there's the cat you know and then
eventually everything gets a lot worse
before it gets better
okay if you're like me and everything
eventually it's up on the floor at some
stage but then you can put in piles and
then you can give some order to the same
things gonna happen heap as we multiply
through you've actually got one two
three four things you multiply it by
right but I can gather some of these
things together for example these guys
out here I'm just going to leave them
out the front because I can't do
anything with is they signify the Camino
okay but when I start to do these guys
of unpack
something interesting emerges right just
like over here pair of things pair of
things I'm just going to multiply
through 1 2 3 2 4 first outside inside
last if that's what you prefer
ok so for example cos alpha x over these
guys so watch cos alpha cos beta the
second one I cos alpha sine beta I'm
just writing them I at the front to make
it really obvious that what I'm not here
he's imaginary there's the first pit now
I'm going to do the second pit for
reasons that will become clear in a
second I'm gonna do them in your verse I
sine alpha times I sine V oh okay we've
been working with eyes for a little bit
now can we just do this directly what's
gonna happen you're gonna get a negative
sometimes I should just write - okay and
then that deals with the eyes then you
got signed out for Sunday yes
okay so I've done that one that one all
right what's that does the imaginary one
that's going to be sine alpha cos V no
and now I've done will for my toes okay
are you getting suspicious yet we said
it would look bad to begin with but now
if you know your extension one
identities well this is just trying to
slap you in the face with an identity
that you know right have a look at these
guys this is why I wrote underneath each
other what is this the real part this is
cos this is cos alpha plus beta this is
the expansion of cos alpha cos beta so
I've got my own got my module I just
sitting at the frontier chilling to the
contrary
and then you've got cos alpha plus beta
but that's what that I didn't need
that's the real part if you take out an
eye and then deal with the imaginary
part over here this is also an identity
you recognize right this is sine alpha
plus beta
okay now we're done that's it
do you see what we've just proven right
if you multiply two complex numbers
together with a modulus and any
arguments what happens to the moduli
well you we should multiply them huh
that's convenient
by the way moduli that's the modulus so
you multiply the moduli what happens to
the angles the arguments you just Adam I
don't know it was because I like
alliteration but someone else does too
this will help you really easily
recognize Aikido but in rectangular form
complex numbers are a pain to multiply
by right can you imagine having to do
like a third or a fourth or fifth one
but in polar form that was a super easy
you just it's as easy as multiplying and
adding now while we're here I want you
to think about this for a second what if
I just took the same number and then
multiplied it by itself many many times
let's just think about saying since is
it I've got Z is defined up there right
a modulus any argument what's gonna
happen to the moduli you're gonna
multiply it right so you've got the same
one to us so you multiply it by itself
so that's just gonna be that modulus
square do you agree with that what's
gonna happen to the English it'll be
doubled right because you're adding
theta to theta right so you're gonna get
cos 2 theta + I sine 2 now transition
anything about me rather as a penis
that's what happens when you square what
happens when you give again you're going
to multiply the radius 3 times that's R
cubed and then you're going to add the
angle three times right so you're going
to get cos 3
sir I see a pattern here
right patterns vanishes love patterns
I've never liked charity four five
forever I can say for any number for any
power you like you just have to multiply
the power by that number of times so I
multiply the modulus that number of
times and what do you do with the angles
you just yeah you just you're adding
them repeatedly right so that's why we
get n wants at that angle and yes you've
got to get Tunes next to each other and
lots of betting now two quick things I
want to say on ministry do you see why
now I serve prefer riding cos theta plus
I sine theta and not sis feet on right
because when you write it in that second
way it kind of clouds what's going on
here there are two different DC that can
interact right and all of our knowledge
of trigonometry can help us here you
can't do this because you're just
writing in that way and secondly this
son relationship down upon here is
really cool it's super super useful they
get to use it a lot in the next coming
weeks okay
and so all useful things get names so
this guy down here I'm gonna write the
name for you and then I'm gonna teach
you how to pronounce it because believe
me it's a big deal again just like
Descartes in the Cartesian plane this
guy another French guy they were really
where it's all hat when it was too much
of geometry this is a fridge man right
so you pronounce this listen carefully
you pronounce this de moivre's theorem
okay like is in you know me muah right
that's how you pronounce that was that
sequence of letters in French okay now I
have heard really serious people
pronounce this like this okay cuz that's
what it kind of looks like right except
the only problem is it's not Spanish
it's not like I was in Chile with my
compadre and his day was to my brain
okay it's not how you pronounce it
please unless you wanna look really
silly to its head like that it's um it's
Dubois
okay so the bonus theorem is a very very
powerful application of polar form and
you can use this to just make mince meat
up can you imagine if you have to do
like three or four or five complex
numbers together in rectangular form
what a nightmare but here this is kind
of like the equivalent of binomial
theorem right now that you guys know
what binomial coefficients are all right
you don't have to fluff around like with
Pascal's triangle so that you can just
go straight to these numbers and that's
what tomorrow sue is for complex numbers
okay right does it have any questions so
what I'd like you to do is I hope some
of you already noticed how how
grindingly frustrating it was in the
exercise to multiply complex numbers in
rectangular form okay that's why now
that you know how to do them in polar
form and once you have a go at some of
those other questions that I didn't
assign in that exercise anywhere where
and excuse me our product is involved
use tomorrow soon or use this to see
this property here now one last thing
this is multiplication what's the UM
what's the inverse of multiplication
again mr. vision okay
now how would you expect it to visions
work if this is how multiplication was
fine
so so the first thing is you don't even
have to write 18 down to know if this is
what you're starting with if you
actually go ahead and do the same thing
all over again which we don't need
you're gonna have to be dividing eyes
and RW they're going to be at the front
right so this is simple you're still
going to be doing this it's just that
multiplication turns into division
that's the universal makes sense
what's the inverse of addition that's
what happens to the angles it's going to
be subtraction so this in here is going
to be not alpha plus beta but
and if you like you're welcome to
rehearses but you can see what's going
to happen right because what you're
doing is you're dividing you're going to
have to get these guys in here there
will be a fracture that's a bit messy
but you're gonna get the same kind of
identities happening if you just kind of
turn recognizes that okay it's a lot
easier now you've done the first one